hello I'm Daryl co from redwood city
which is near San Francisco and guess
where we're at we're at the berlin wall
at the east side gallery come let's go
explore with me berlin a little bit
I remember the first time I saw the wall
it was a couple years before they took
it down and there was a fellow that
tried to escape and I can hear the
yelling and I we saw the guards pull him
into the guardhouse it made a big
impression on me I'm so happy the walls
down now no city should ever have a wall
come on guys let's go on to take the
subway and do some more exploring
this is our next stop the Berlin tech
museum and I love mechanical and old
things so let's get started and take a
look around there is be exciting Wow a
letter set printer I haven't seen one of
these in real can I try that
what's so special about this museum here
is this got so much history it goes back
hundreds of years so there's no telling
what you're going to see around the next
corner wow that's an old douglas c-47
I'll bet they use that in the Berlin
lift
I sure AM hungry and I'd like to try
some famous Berlin currywurst here
underneath the subway station people
tell me there's a very best curry wars
in all of Berlin the name of it as
cannabis and I think we should try it
right now
it's just perfect was in Berlin and
beautiful town and now traffic we've got
roads going and going every way the
trolley is coming by it's just beautiful
the weather is very nice to crazed the
best this is a reason why I came to
Berlin to bring my organ and I'm going
to play in the music festival today so
come on let's get going
everybody loves this music all over a
Berlin they've especially loved it
because it has a lot of history in
Berlin what a wonderful ending to a
wonderful day touring around Berlin I
hope you enjoyed it as much as I did ah
Peter same office they are you saying
bye if you're planning a trip to Germany
let us know we'd like to meet you and
record your experiences for the show if
you're selected you will receive a
special DVD as a souvenir of your German
holiday just drop us a line at discover
Germany at DW de we're looking forward
to meeting you
you